all right welcome to my first video
bought a new laptop and it's an HP
Pavilion TV 2nd T so of course I've got
the media center remote with it this is
the first video I'm uploading to over a
million subscribers on YouTube kind of a
ridiculous number and when you think of
tech on YouTube the first name that
probably pops up is marques Brownlee or
better known as mkbhd so this is the
studio as you can see I'm really glad I
found it everything about this car is
fast now by the numbers you would expect
that it's a video series to showcase the
most impressive bleeding-edge super
high-end or just straight-up
awesome tech that makes its way to the
studio that does miss I first discovered
him in high school when he was still
filming in the legendary college dorm
room and as the years went by he's
gotten pretty big computing tasks that
we used to think well I'm gonna get to
do that sitting down at a desk with a
full computer and now people like what
the heck I'm doing it on me you've your
notes here on a phone right right I have
two actually one consumer one and one
developer what is that cheating do you
guys see yourself just keeping a tight
ship and picking your your choices here
and there it's a tough strategic call
between focus and like me wanting to do
a bunch of different models like so how
did he get to this point where he's
getting a million views a day and is one
of the most influential voices in the
space welcome to the dream phone 2019 so
this is something I thought a lot about
there is no perfect phone there never
has been and even with tech getting
better and better and amazing phones out
now it kind of feels like there never
will be
it's coming out and you just you just
nail it you just you're so you're my
go-to guy man well thank you that's
quite an intra that's what we're here to
find out in today's analysis of marques
Brownlee how did he get here and how you
can do the same so sit back relax and
let's get into it
[Music]
at the time of reading this video he's
creeping up to ten million subscribers
and since he's never publicly stated it
if we estimate extremely conservatively
he's probably making at least a thousand
dollars a day from YouTube ads alone or
three hundred sixty five thousand
dollars per year but let's be real it's
probably a lot more than that this is
also not including how much he makes
through affiliate links sponsorship
deals and selling his own merch so yeah
he's he's making Bank I'm still at a
point where like the YouTube ads are
probably 40 40 to 50 percent I don't do
a whole lot of sponsored stuff if I did
that number would be much higher but I
think right now sponsored stuff is
probably about twenty percent so 40 20
and then affiliate stuff being another
ten so where I like what 70 now so I
guess yeah YouTube ads is probably a
bigger YouTube ad is probably 50 percent
of what the the streams look like but it
definitely wasn't always like this to
see how it started we have to take a
trip back to the year 2005
[Music]
Hurricane Katrina was in full swing the
Xbox 360 was just released that future
starts right here right now pop music
was actually kind of decent the best TV
show ever premiered its first season and
this little-known site called YouTube
was created like I'm a full time
youtuber who employs two dozen people
and even I had no idea back then that
the site would explode into a platform
that would allow people to make a
full-time living by uploading videos
that other people watch for free fast
forward to 2009 and YouTube was
dominated by cat video Smosh Fred and
the like and in New Jersey a little 13
year old by the name of marques just got
a brand new HP laptop probably from
Christmas and decided to record a review
of the little media remote that came
with it little did he know that this
very video would lead him to running one
of the most respected YouTube channels
on the platform
when answering the question on how to
make a million dollars without having to
wait 20 years X Gogol Facebook tech Li
millionaire explained it like this right
let's say you don't want to wait 20
years and that really has to do with
writing waves waves open up big
opportunities for anybody and it becomes
very easy to make money you don't have
to struggle so much there's just going
to be opportunity everywhere and that's
what happened to Marquez he rode the
wave of YouTube and gained what's called
the first mover's advantage whether we
look at the wave of venture capitalist
investors throwing every dollar they had
into tech companies during the dot-com
bubble or the wave of real estate since
the Great Recession or the introduction
of Apple's App Store or Facebook's apps
and the thousands of millionaires that
were minted overnight riding the waves
of change makes everything in business
easier you gain support easier you make
money easier and you grow a lot faster
especially when you're at the very start
of a wave and you have that first
mover's advantage because when Marquez
launched that first tech review way back
in 2009 there was this giant unmet need
of tech videos on YouTube yet there were
basically no other competitors out there
besides his channel called NCIX tech
tips on top of that this was around the
exact same time that the market of
smartphones was just about to explode
and as tech companies kept innovating
and impressing the public this niche of
people interested in the latest tech
products kept growing and the best way
to meet this niche of tech YouTube the
obvious answer there is tech has been
interesting and important for so long
that just being in a tech space
generally for that long has has done a
lot for it so that was the playing field
that marques was in an entire giant
marketplace where he was free to
experiment and prove make a ton of
mistakes and even take a break from
YouTube for a while and still come out
on top before all the other tech
youtubers really started flooding in
where if he started today where there
are way more tech youtubers the
smartphone market isn't growing
exponentially anymore sure it would
still be 100% possible for marques to
grow but what started
a way for a blue ocean of opportunity
over ten years ago has slowed down and
turned into a little bit more of a red
ocean of tech channels so what's the
first reason marques became the king of
tech new tubers he had the first mover's
advantage and rode the two waves of
YouTube and tech riding waves and having
the first mover's advantage definitely
isn't required for success because if it
was there wouldn't be any other new
channels and gaining any traction but
you got to admit having those advantages
definitely does help and as you've seen
these concepts don't just relate to
YouTube in fact the initial wave of
YouTube is pretty much over
but that definitely doesn't mean you
can't experience márquez's kind of
growth it might just have to be with
another wave in another industry it's
been 10 years since the initial YouTube
wave started the last wave before that
was a dot-com wave which was another 10
years before the YouTube wave started so
who knows maybe there's another way of
happening right now underneath the
mainstream radar now you might be the
right fit to ride I've got my eyes on
one of them right now but maybe we'll
reserve that for another video
[Music]
when I started going into some research
for this video I was wondering the same
question you're probably wondering right
now was there a point where everything
just started taking off for Marquez when
everything just seemed to click and
skyrocket and if there was what was it
let's let Marquez answer that for us no
I get asked that a lot about like you
know can I point to a certain video or
date or month or something like what
happened to go from like nothing to
where it is now because I've from to
this day I look back and it's mainly
just like it you can look at charts even
it's just a sort of an upward slope from
0 videos to a thousand videos so if
there wasn't that moment that just
changed everything what was it then
riding a wave is great and all but just
because you're on the wave just because
you're one of the first movers it
doesn't guarantee your success it's not
as simple as just waking up one day
noticing the potential of YouTube in the
tech space starting a channel and then
boom your mkbhd and when I was writing
this video I was kind of hoping for some
elaborate genius answer but no matter
how much I was pulling my hair out to
find one sometimes the answer is just
simple as like this dude is just really
obsessed over a tech because think about
it for men that practically has
everything a person could ever want fame
fortune an extremely lucrative business
where he just spends all day playing
with the latest tech he has son the best
tech videos on YouTube and it's
basically just living the life if you
were in his shoes it would be pretty
tempting to just sit back and enjoy that
sweet and YouTube money but even though
he's made it
what is his only concern right now ok
I'm still on that quest of production
like I know my videos can be better like
they're they're still always a gap
between like a great YouTube video and a
movie of course like it everyone can
tell a YouTube video from a movie and
everything but like I ideally that like
seamless like production where I can
tell the story I want show what I want
to show
and not have any barriers in the way as
far as production that would be ideal
that's probably my biggest challenge the
man has everything in all he's concerned
about the only thing that keeps him up
at night is how he can make his videos
more realistic overly realistic but to
the point where like if you look at this
video on your screen you'll feel the
closest to actually holding it and
realize like that's the goal so even
though yes the wave of YouTube in tech
and the fact that Markus start at the
best possible moment like ever did
greatly contribute to his odds of
success but it's not the whole picture
because there are probably a lot of
other people that knows this trend and
start a tech channel around them as well
but as far as I know you don't hear
about any of them today
besides Lynas tech tips because it takes
more than just jumping on a wave to gain
his level of notoriety it takes what's
called being naturally inclined towards
the arena natural inclinations being
naturally inclined towards something as
a term coined by one of the greatest
authors alive today named Robert Greene
and in his book mastery he explained
that being naturally inclined towards
something isn't necessarily the same as
being passionate about something it's
more about things in life that you've
always just naturally gravitated towards
on a primitive level for as long as you
can remember because think about it
what kind of thirteen-year-old makes a
video about a computer remote back when
no one knew about the potential of
YouTube someone that's always been
naturally inclined towards tech who has
always been intuitively geeking out over
the latest tech gadget who just
naturally wants to make things as
realistic as possible not because it's a
great business opportunity but because
it's just really cool to him um yeah
there was always I did all these
tutorial videos which are just
screencast so it's just my screen at a
mouse moving and I was obsessed with
getting the highest frame rate possible
and the smoothest motion blur of my
cursor on the screen like that it's so
stupid but like I've always wanted that
production to facilitate the story as as
best as possible
I want the quality to be like
as realistic as a candy so that it's not
a distraction because if you're not
naturally inclined towards what you're
doing if you're just going after it
because you see that it's the next big
trend you're not gonna last ten plus
years in fact you're gonna get pretty
damn bored after you review like a
hundred phones that in retrospect are
pretty much the exact same phones except
for a few slight nuances here and there
so how did Marquez get here well if we
look past the great video quality if we
look past all the expensive camera gear
and all the cliche crap that everyone
talks about like consistency hard work
and hustle I think at the core Marquez's
success is partially because he rode the
wave of YouTube and tech at the perfect
time and he was naturally inclined
towards tech enough to be the perfect
fit for this wave
[Music]
so thank you so much for being part of
me watch the end Club you guys and if
you are new here I'm thinking about
calling this new series I'm doing like
the why I'm winning series and I'll link
to a few other videos I made just like
this one in the video description below
or in like the car on the screen and
stuff and if you want to see more and
you enjoy the style of video for the
entrepreneur niche please consider
subscribing and turning on that
notification bell so that you team
notifies you whenever I release a new
video and in classic MQ PhD fashion
thanks for watching get you guys the
next one
[Music]
[Music]